I thought nobody seemed excited at all
for the team I don't even know who I'm
with I was adjusting my mouth since I'm
waiting I'm with you Bob I'm good thank
God there was new stuff in the picture
and the thing was no I swear yeah it's
different
see largely the same under water we have
so many good memories from this map I
thought it would be good to start out
with good memories you would Bob do
that's right yeah yeah I haven't
forgotten the buckle of 24 2014 we all
had a good time that day yeah it was
pretty fun wait are you guys hiding
already wait a minute yeah no we're
waiting on you to kill us before we
decide to go hide what they do wait can
you see that where are you yeah
all right Bob I'm gonna be scouting from
up here so if I say any more certain I'm
fairly certain that they're in the water
probably underwater or not that's stupid
yeah well that's what I'm saying but you
know what what was that sound was that
was that you wade were you doing a thing
over there
Oh huh I can't I can't see well from my
vantage point
uh-huh so you're out of it what what a
professional mark who are professional
knows to have the phone on silent when
you start the recording hang on I'm
keeping an eye balls out okay somebody's
totally in the cage area
oh my evil eye is finally paid
right ego Jack when I'm spotting yes
we're in here are you
that's my question looking at you I know
I feel you're looking at me Bob that is
I'm the one in the glass box oh no I'm
not in there yes all right
why was this door open I feel like now
that was Wade Wade was moving the door
all around like an idiot here I've been
watching very closely so we got a minute
and 45 I can't wait wait a minute what
do you mean what do you mean I just flew
past Bob I think if that was mark still
up top yeah that was me yeah I always in
the water but I can't see I can't see to
the water yeah I can't freak it out of
me and I can't see anything
all right Bob I'm gonna hang at the whoo
okay no that was a fish what no idea
where you guys are I can't see you
anymore still underwater yeah okay what
the music's jaws wait but first wait
what does it take to sell out your team
mate nothing I offer all to do it for
10,000 subscribers okay I saw him I saw
blood where'd he go nobody go nope nope
it was closer than you might think but
farther than you buy it left damnit I
can't throw grenades and stuff under
water
I know normal fish fish outta water boy
I was thinking weird a grenade okay good
wait a minute
oh did Jack did you get out of the water
I think
uh-oh we're being made a fool of I
thought you had gotten better at this
[Laughter]
plant he was exactly where you were the
bone fish were think he was right here
mark we're right here
oh okay around a good bit though that
would have made sense you guys just suck
thank ya DEP for whatever you gonna kill
me then you're good you're very talented
oh then they suck even more oh hey Mark
don't forget the lie about that but what
I found what I can't I don't know where
you went I can't see you anymore
I really like chance to get more ammo
and guns Rob you don't know you don't
know about that chest why would I need
them the car just drive boy yeah yeah
there's a car animation on the edge of
the map I've never noticed new it's cuz
it's it's like louder than it used to be
or something it used to be very quiet
here chopper wait what wait no one's in
that corner you don't need to be in that
corner Bob no not in the fountain
dum-dum you don't know that I don't
think I don't think that's right wait
that's not the one Wade are you a fish
no yes are you a barrel are you trying
to know confuse them with your words yes
[Applause]
no I'm not a barrel either I was just
trying to make fun of mark thank you
garbage I'll jump for you is that every
time I say it every time I say Boing
I'll jump how about that oh boy oh boy
oh boy oh boy this you're not above
water oh boy yes I'm definitely not
above water boy we've rekindled our
winning ways yeah yeah I I think it was
just maybe a little there they were on
the hunt for it they were there ready
for our moves I can't believe we finally
came back together mark yeah it's been
ages take a while you know spin all the
way inside me and I kind of liked it I'm
an endurance man is the way it is hmm
gross Thanks that sounds awful yeah
just just don't talk again man all right
who's around here shall we choice wait
wait wait wait wait
oh holy by the way by the way Bob you
have like minds so I'm gonna play some
mind at at read minds you have a mind
yes yes at a choke point so if they go
by it
[Laughter]
I heard it's all loose hey stop that
stop shooting don't come in here you get
out a likely story
where they have honestly why aren't you
moving fish trust me what's going on Bob
well sorry Bob some recon I feel like I
accidentally threw my mind right at one
of them and then Jack was all like no
hang on a second where near me hang on a
second wait a second some Oh Tommy right
so I'm eight right with this fish never
mind that okay what's going on there was
not a prop delivery service this game
are freaking me out
oh it's my theme song what there's
something going on here something's
[ __ ] mysterious file box moving
around mmm see you okay so Bob
that means Wade's down here somewhere
all right cuz if Jax is watching 20
seconds ago when that happened yeah yeah
no it's time I was a plant on the
surface when I got stuck and I couldn't
change so Wade brought me a fish sure
yeah that's what you want us to think
make a fool of us that's what we want us
to think wait how are you guys breathing
underwater water filtration [ __ ]
magic how do you what do you hear
explosion up wanted to catch someone up
there
magicJack [ __ ] magic you do it wait I
believe in you
where yeah we got this I got this like
the Silver Surfer got hang on a second I
really man way to manually just don't I
don't even feel like I'm doing well
today at the prop hunting no not that
okay there's a phone a cone has been
displaced over here where is he
well caught a side of him no my my
reticle passed by him I saw his name pop
up so I'm like off I throw a grenade in
this general direction I might get him
no oh he's up top Bob he's he's up top I
lost him again oh wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
I feel like you've got a bomb left
come on both yeah we're after so many
years we're starting to not trust Bob
it's a minute can I go back over here no
you can do it I can't [ __ ] shoot the
tiny fish I'm not gonna just run around
and look like an [ __ ]
Bob Bob I'm going out on my own terms
I can't shoot that little fish like that
I'm not good enough I'm not gonna do it
I'm not gonna play that game that's oh
yeah and now because if you'll remember
I'm never [ __ ] tiny fish I'm always a
stupid barrel who dies really fast
all right the barrel this is
bad idea what if they decided to go for
the obvious and be a fish in a barrel
that would be too much it's too
brilliant yeah I agree
that's part of it
Oh oh dear oh gosh we're opening the
gate no what no we're not
you don't know that I got yelled at for
Oprah to get two rounds ago you guys
don't know you're doing you guys
something happen out here it seems some
of the area's you go to you can see
through the wall I know you can see [ __ ]
ah
I basically won't know anything until
I'm dead I died that's a real catfish
all right tingling what are you talking
about I don't think that's the sense
that's tingling Jagr not the juices
that's not how it works why is
everything juicy with you it doesn't
need to be juicy fruits why do you wear
those sweatpants a juicy on the ass all
the time Jack yeah it makes sense I like
my juicy ass it's not even that juicy
it's so juicy I've had juicier
except you didn't share with friends my
ass there was there was there always be
a ttle what specifically are you
representing lots of things happened in
Seattle have to pick one of the clubs
and which no nothing happens
nothing's nowhere nothing which prompts
anymore Wow bob and weave
holy [ __ ] Kenny Wow Wow
my mistake I didn't know we always do I
accidentally grabbed onto that barrel
and I didn't know where Oh Bob that is
that is a good spot
I'm not even saying that sarcastically
no it's good it's pretty good
I'm proving a point I'm proving a point
yeah I get what you're saying it's it's
like an artistic statement yeah it's
well it's political you have to really
look into it it's political if it is me
what can we do about I did not become a
tiny fish yeah I was in the room the
first room that you check check the the
computer room I was in there mmm see me
dum-dum I wasn't to be to be fair to you
it wasn't the shark when I was in there
right right
okay Bob I'll start looking underwater
first just to get it out of the way
don't develop a strategy and then Bob
you be devious and get them emotionally
okay okay wait you have you ever noticed
when you're looking in the mirror about
your hair what do you say like got the
top front part some some people there's
hair all the way on that right when
we're talking about how we're gonna rip
on way today was that on the list of yes
or no I'm very yes I've read the list
wrong here shark music but I don't
okay that is that like a taunt or is
that just like a box on the move box on
the move by the room by the room Pilar
and Bob I heard the door open your back
[Laughter]
our key the emotional warfare holy work
look in the mirror than that time that I
did and then did you grow the hair on
their face really well you know how like
all the way down their neck and you know
how when you look in the mirror a couple
of months ago and you didn't have all
that
mark mark wants to be insulted that's
the problem that's having here I really
am NOT up think about this spot but I'm
trying to get creative me neither yeah
I'm trying to be a bit differential
Friday I'm trying to do something here
yeah make statement aside for oh it's
fish Cohen was pretty classic you know
pre-classic it's hard to top fish comb
and well it will never be the same as
[Laughter]
what I get for trying something new yeah
we're gonna be devious and douchey we're
gonna we're gonna pull real Wade next
time you better watch out I believe I'm
not sure what you're on about mark oh
you know I really don't start losing I'm
sorry I'm sorry you can't go back to it
it's probably not effective anymore he's
he's all cried out you can only kill
jack
I'll take mark to kill Jackie okay you
first well I don't think we can kill
each other well if we let you live will
you grant us three wishes yes I have to
think about this one okay I wish wait
doesn't like me I'm gonna let you have
your wishes mark and I'm cool I wish
upon a star for a brand new car I've got
one I just I left it in my back let me
go I'm just gonna go get it okay okay
where you going you keep being you I'll
be back with your new I trust you I got
I got the cure this will this will fix
you zapped sticks didn't do the work man
you know yeah I'm shocked yeah I'm more
than shocked me yeah cocked
I don't want to ruin your fun Jack you
know you're probably having a good time
I'm having a great spot I'm not moving
jack you are in a great spot hey Jack
right you're lucky I can't what the hell
where is he he's he was down here I saw
his name pop up I just didn't I couldn't
get a lock on what item II was this
might be the greatest win might be see
see what happens mark is really dumb I
am incredibly stupid so I pull the old
wish shark technique yeah we really got
wish start what the hell people are
gonna use that I don't know what's
happening right now
what's going on did you run away and I
didn't notice it maybe look really bad
mark no he's still here
I knew you were still there you survived
the grenade I have no idea he's a little
wiener yeah he was a little wiener he
may not have been winner of the whole
time but how did you survive over there
five seconds ago I was just looking over
there oh he was right behind your head I
was the cabbage on the table and you
like dropped a grenade right in front of
my face I know what the hell well that's
a tough case yeah like your I was
scanning every item and your name wasn't
popping up it was so weird
[Music]